c'est pas des soucis de santé du loup
nous il a mal au dos au tu n'en fais pas
ça c'est le ca mais alors pourquoi j'ai
mal au dos un tabassage peux pas vous
dire je suis pas psychologue vous allez
bien oui comme ça les choses ne se
passent pas comme prévu 1 tu as
travaillé dur un texte du projet je
passe son temps que laisser marcher sur
les pieds via pas tu t'étonnes d'avoir
mal au dos c'est quand même pas de ma
faute si je bosse avec un salon non mais
c'est pas faux si tu te laisses faire
c'est toujours comme ça c'est pareil
avec tout ça va je peux dormir chez vous
cette nuit rien ne vaut de s'occuper
d'un ami dépressif pour solidifier un
coup c'est une femme et à [ __ ] des
galères
à ce moment je ne passe beaucoup de
temps dans les soldats tentent d'aller
voir cette manie 10 est formidable c'est
vous que de formule 1 et que vous dit
votre dos pardon cherchez bien
la réponse étant à merci un peu mou du
montage parfois c'est une journée
spéciale
aujourd'hui je règle mes contacts en
1991 je me suis fait massacrer les
cheveux ici tu m'as dit quelque chose de
gentil il dit un truc gentil basics
thème bien sa coupe de cheveux de
psychorigide board et intolérante est
susceptible en plus ça fait du bien
c'est vrai
[Musique]
j'avais théorie quand même j'ai pu je
crois pas
[Musique]